hello i'm darren pemberton deputy leader
of stratford-on-avon district council
and lead member for planning policy we
are consulting on the site allocations
plan
to inform decisions about a number of
areas including how employment land is
provided
the work was underway before the
pandemic but it is even more important
as we support the economy
and its recovery from kobit 19.
we are proposing a new draft policy sap
8
in chapter 5 of the plan setting out how
our new approach to encouraging
new employment sites for industrial or
commercial premises will work
so why are we proposing this new
approach
what research technical evidence and
employer feedback
gathered across the district and more
widely in warwickshire tells us
is that there is a significant shortage
of affordable employment land available
this is slowing down the creation of new
businesses and more importantly is
stopping many of our existing businesses
in their growth plans
and their ability to employ more people
simply because they cannot
find affordable sites to move on to the
core strategy didn't
identify new employment sites to meet
the expected level of growth
however these sites are more and more
being snapped up by multinationals in
sectors such as logistics
to support the exponential growth in
online shopping
and so driving much higher rents because
the existing employment land supply
cannot meet the sea change in consumer
habits over the last few years
on the one hand this is great news for
the district because we are getting much
needed inward investment
the real downside is that existing local
businesses are being priced out of local
growth opportunities
in the long term this will create a
lopsided employment base
that will hamper economic growth and
will not maximize sustainable jobs
our new approach is to encourage new
employment sites
in close proximity to existing
settlements and or existing employment
sites
that are subject to satisfying a range
of site-specific criteria
to ensure that the sites themselves are
indeed suitable for development in
planning terms
in addition we are creating the concept
of affordable employment sites
in the same way that we do for housing
we will require developers to provide 20
of floor space as affordable employment
space
with that space charging a maximum of 75
percent of local market commercial rents
so we'd like to hear your views on this
approach have we got it right
do you think it will work at the very
least given the current impacts of
curvid 19 on the local economy
i think it's important for us to be
innovative in our approaches to the
problem
if we don't try anything new we won't
ever know how we can improve things
as your local authority it is our job to
do what we can to support
local businesses employment and the
economy so please as many of you as
possible need to make your views known
details of how to comment can be found
at www.stratfor.gov dot uk
forward slash sapo and the consultation
runs until 5 pm
on friday the 18th of december so please
let me have your comments
thank you